foreign
what's up guys I'm Dave Ramsey and we're
back with another episode of real estate
the Ramsay way this one is all about
buying a home the right way it can be
exciting it can be stressful but it is
always a huge decision that comes with a
lot of emotions and you should feel
confident about what you're doing before
you hit the ground running and start
shopping so stick around for the home
buying advice that you're not going to
get anywhere else
I'm 20 years old and I'm looking to buy
a house within six months to a year
besides having 20 down what other tips
would you recommend for a first-time
homebuyer also is there anything that I
need to look out for
um yeah I would say there's a couple of
things to keep in mind I think it's
great that you're putting 20 percent
down uh we would say to do a deal where
your payment is no more than 25 of your
take home and that's taxes Insurance all
included in a conventional loan and I
love that you're putting 20 down because
then you can avoid PMI which is private
mortgage insurance and it's just an
additional cost there but with 20 down
you can avoid that but I feel like
you're in pretty good shape I mean other
than that it sounds sounds pretty good
to me yeah a couple of things good idea
good question by the way 15-year fixed
rate 25 percent of your take-home pay
um always
everyone
anytime you buy a piece of real estate
get title insurance
100 of the time
anytime you're buying a piece of
property that is not a traditional
subdivision lot
meaning it's very very predictable
always get a survey
so if you you know about three acres it
turned out to be 1.75 no that yeah no we
uh we you get a survey on it okay now
you got a standard subdivision lot that
is pre-platted and has changed hands
three or four times you have to worry
about that it is what it is but uh if
you're buying something otherwise get a
survey get title insurance and get a
home inspection
get a home inspection you're 20 years
old you're not an expert on much of
anything in that house uh unless you're
just I happen to be an electrician or
something and then you would be right
but
um yeah get it get a home inspection
period
um I bought the sold several thousand
pieces of real estate I get a home
inspection last house I bought I got one
okay I can go in there and scratch
around in the crawl space and try to
figure it out but for what it costs to
let somebody else do it right
um
that's the thing uh don't buy a house
that is a great price but is ugly
from the street
first house I bought was that I got a
great deal and this house was
ugly from the street
there's no fixing ugly yeah you can't
fix ugly okay it's just still gonna be
no well we could we could no don't don't
don't don't try to fix ugly ugly you
just look like you you know oh I had
plastic surgery and you shouldn't have
bothered oh don't do it you know I mean
I mean don't you just can't fix it leave
it alone just don't don't it's not a
good buy because if you get a good buy
on it now when you get ready to sell it
you know what you have an ugly house
and you're gonna give somebody else a
good deal because nobody wants an ugly
house so that there's a reason it was
cheap when you bought it and there'll be
a reason it's cheap when you sell it so
and that's also true with the actual
floor plan
I bought a house one time no actually I
didn't buy I rented it one time that was
a four bedroom but to get to one of the
bedrooms you had to walk through the
other bedroom oh yeah that's terrible
terrible we used to call these country
built houses where you just keep adding
on
and you just go yeah well there there
was actually no plan from the beginning
yeah and then you've got no plan so be
careful with that kind of stuff you can
you can get excited particularly on your
first buy and uh try to buy something
that's a little bit boring
that's good advice you know don't try to
like reinvent the world I'm gonna do a
rehab oh God no well I mean you could
pick you could pick something that's got
things that you can fix like if the
carpet's super ugly there's things that
are outdated like you can you can change
that but you can put you can put the
gutters up that's fine but don't tell me
you got to change though no yeah I gotta
tear out I gotta add no no no no no no
just you just boring means less risk
going in and less risk going out and so
a nice little house with a little picket
fence and little bushes out front and it
looks you look at it from the street and
everybody goes oh that's cute that's
that's where you want to start what do
you think about Corner Lots because when
we bought in our neighborhood before we
came here we thought we had a good luck
because we were on the corner by the
gate and for us it was great we thought
oh we could take the dog out it's easy
access but then when we got ready to
sell
because generally Corner Lots present
well from the street right but you have
no freaking backyard you got this little
tiny triangle back there where they
crammed the house back inside at a 45
and so it depends on the subdivision
depends on the lot size right all those
kinds of things but generally speaking
you get a nice presentation from the
front and then you're pinched in the
back yeah that's generally what you get
so watch for that that's not the end of
the world but watch for that again if
you've got a concern when you're looking
at it know that they're the buyer when
you get ready to sell it's going to have
the same concern so just don't right
don't get so excited you rationalize
your way into stupidity I know a guy
who's done that a lot in his life and um
that's how he has a radio show so be
careful hurt is in Fort Lauderdale
Florida hi Kurt how are you
hey Dave how you doing better than I
deserve man what's up
how you doing um I'm 25 I'm not filled
with my job and I'd like to move out of
my parents house
um potentially looking up North but I
have about 50 000 in Investments and 90
000 in my savings and I'm blessed to
have no debt um should I move with the
current housing market situation and
should I wait and if I should wait
should I move some of that savings money
into investment make some money while
I'm waiting
well um the housing market as you
mentioned is white hot in terms of
buying a home
uh some areas the rental market is also
closed up and it's very difficult to
find a rental and so rental prices are
going up as fast as real estate prices
are which there should be a correlation
between the two that makes sense
um
so uh uh
you have done a wonderful job saving
money sir well done you save all this
money or somebody give it to you
um I'd say about half maybe a little
less than half is an inheritance to my
uncle arrest is all just me saving uh my
my father and my mother since I was
young have always told them you know
spend half safe half and I just was
never really a big spender so I saved
more than half of that point wow and so
I've just been saving uh for I've been
working since I was you know 16 so I've
been sitting for a while now and I'm
just I've always been looking forward to
buying a house and I just was feeling
now is the right time but with this
housing market I'm just ugh it's kind of
shot down my house you said you might
move up north what are you going to do
for a living when you move
oh I stay within the same industry but
right now I probably don't want
analytics that's what I like to do right
now I do
um more risk management
um so Kurt get into more analytical so
I'm glad we've identified this because
moving up north I think you had in mind
uh there's some companies or a company
or a specific job and I think that's the
part we want to work on first is you're
not happy in your job and so you know
the good news is you're clear you know
what you want to do you have a good idea
of the analytics is where you want to go
I think I determined that where's a good
place to land there then I'd make my
housing decision based on that
okay so do you have a good idea of some
companies or do you have something when
you say move north are you just thinking
an area or are you thinking company
that's pulling you North
um I was thinking more just Orlando or
Jacksonville because I have a current
social networks there
um that would you know and finding a job
there's obviously a lot of within my
industry there's a lot in Orlando and
Jacksonville I was looking there just to
kind of get away from where I was where
I've currently been where I've lived all
my life you know sure well that's really
good strategy so Kurt I I think you now
you need to take some action steps and
so I I would begin if you haven't
already you obviously have the social
networks there I would actually begin to
engage those social networks around
those companies you identified both
friends connections and uh several
companies that are in your industry or
at least you know that it's pretty hot
there I'd start making those connections
I'm going to give you a copy of my
number one best-selling book The
Proximity principle which actually walks
you through step by step how to make
those connections who specifically
you're looking at because I think if you
get really serious about that Kurt right
now you're in great shape financially
let's find those opportunities let's go
ahead and get interviews let's land the
gig and I think the housing decision uh
will take care of itself because you've
been very smart with your money but
let's land uh a job and then let's make
a housing decision as a part of that
yeah here's what I I will just add to
that let's take that I'll take the back
end of that strategy so start working
the social networks you're only a few
hours from those towns get the job
landed then go rent an apartment for six
months
then during that six months start
looking for property don't overpay
there's no reason for you to have house
fever you can take your time and if the
Market's quite hot and you have to
dramatically overpay to get a house then
that's God saying don't buy a house
right now
[Music]
this Market can feel like a roller
coaster but you can be prepared to face
this thing head on check out our free
home buyers guide for everything you
need to know from home search to signing
check out the link in the show notes or
go to ramseysolutions.com buyer
hi Maria welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave very excited to talk to you
thank you
sure my
mic and then I'll give you the
background okay is it Financial is it
friendly just financially speaking not
not regarding how I feel about home
ownership just financially speaking I'm
58 years old
I I I have no debt I have fully funded
emergency fund I have fully funded
retirement both Roth and 40K how much I
own my how much is in it there's about a
million in it okay
um good for you well done between the
between the both I raised my four kids
are all out of college
um I'm single and I my home's worth
about 350 and I paid it off it's paid
off okay taxes are really high taxes are
really high in Illinois
okay but anyway so I I think I want to
downsize because I don't need my house
anymore cool and I'm not I I I so I
would go to like a townhouse okay so
just financially just financially
speaking it wouldn't be a really bad
idea for the next 30 years for me just
to rent and the reason why I asked that
it's because in my heart I've had so
much responsibility in my whole life
raising my four kids keeping up with my
house I wouldn't mind just writing a
check every month and just be done and
uh finding it but everybody's telling me
like financially speaking you could sell
your house to 350. go buy something
within 50 or less I'm like but then I
thought you know then I gotta worry
about the house again the windows the
roofs the gutters the all that you know
[Music]
no yeah it makes a lot of sense I
understand so uh did you raise your kids
by yourself or your single mom
for the most part I mean I was divorced
and they were very very young he was he
was so for 20 years for 20 years you've
been a she bear out here fighting
scratching clawing and you've cleaned
the gutters you've done whatever it took
and you're just tired
all the time every month it worked yeah
sure I was yeah
I thought you were that girl you sound
like that girl
you sound like a warrior a Warrior
Princess
um
so uh
well let's first answer your question
then let's try to look for a solution
okay the problem with your the good part
about your theory is you don't have to
screw with stuff because the landlord
does so you get all this stuff out of
your life the bad part about this is
think about what rents have done in the
last 30 years
you think and think about what they're
going to do during the 30 years that
we're talking so if you rent instead of
owning a paid for property going into
retirement you're destabilizing your
life because every year your housing
cost is going to go up
true
so that's why it's a bad plan
it's not a bad plan to rent for a short
period of time while you're rearranging
things or you're in a transitionary
stage or something like that but renting
for 30 years means you are a victim of
the real estate market instead of riding
the wave
can I do something else
yep
stressing me out if I put that on paper
my taxes versus all my bills in my house
oh I think you need to I think you need
to move
okay but like I I even projected cost if
I was in a townhouse yeah here's what
here's what I want you to do here's what
I would do if you're my little sister
and you're old enough to be my little
sister okay
um not your older sister no I'm 60. so I
got you beat but the uh uh but so uh I
would tell you you don't want to work on
crap and you don't want crap breaking
and you are a millionaire
so you need to go and buy a brand new
condominium where someone does all the
exterior maintenance and every Appliance
and everything inside is brand freaking
new you earned it you're a rock star and
you need to enjoy a little bit of this
money and it's like buying a really nice
car that's in really good shape after
you've been driving a freaking beater
and it breaks down all the time and you
know my cars don't break down now
back when I had crap cars because I was
trying to get here they broke down all
the time but you're a warrior girl and
you need to you need to enjoy The Spoils
of the battles that you have won and
that's a million dollars and a 350 000
paid for house you're worth a million
and a half dollars I want you to sell
this house I want you to buy 350 000
condo you may want to move uh to an area
that is that probably might feel a
little bit oh like it's a little too
Richie Rich for you but you need to live
there anyway
wow okay
okay transition when you it's when
you're a single mom when you're raising
kids and you're putting them through
college and you're saving you're working
you're doing overtime it's kind of like
being gazelle intense for 20 30 years
and suddenly you're uh your identity is
I'm a sprinter I'm a fighter that's what
I do yeah and how do you settle back
down you could hear like man for someone
who's accomplished but she's
accomplished the fact that this decision
is keeping her up means it's not about
this decision it's about I've got to
shift gears and become something else
right that's a big big transition yeah
what do you do when you come home
from a 20-year campaign
on the road with Alexander the Great and
you're one of his soldiers after 20
years how do you stop
fighting and scratching you will pick
your neighbors
you know and so you know and that's what
she issues a warrior princess that's
right and so you know she's been these
single moms man they get her done these
are some of the toughest people in on
our planet and
um so yeah that that's uh
and that's who she is and and she's like
I you know she's kind of telling herself
good things like I deserve a rest that's
right and and Dave we talk a lot about
people making decisions out of stress or
out of
um anxiousness
that's very similar to making decisions
out of exhaustion I'm just I'm done I'm
out right I just wanna I know the math
is bad I know it's going to destabilize
me 20 years from now I'm exhausted I
don't want to fix anything else I want
to talk to any more freaking repairman
I've talked to people who get divorced
because I'm just tired of it right so I
love your I love your idea of man right
now it feels good it's not going to be
good down the road no it's a bad
long-term plan
when you get desperate
afraid
or angry
the higher thinking parts of your brain
shut down
and you don't make
good decisions so I have found in my
life once I get if I get greedy
if I get
afraid if I get desperate right after
that I get stupid
and right after I get stupid I get broke
ER
and so that's what's happening in the
housing market right now
because oh God the house prices are up
and oh God the interest rates went up
and oh God
oh God we're gonna be able to get a
house oh
and once your brain starts doing that
you're getting ready to do something
stupid party's over there's going to be
a lot of regret and they call into this
show and go Dave I did something stupid
Dave help me where were you three years
ago when I was doing something stupid
I'm sitting right here that's where I've
been for 30 years
and I'm still telling you the same
things
about money because these principles
that we teach are Timeless now we teach
people to get out of debt to stay out of
debt when it comes to a house it's the
only debt we don't yell at you for and
we always have told you and we still
will tell you even with the house prices
so high to get a 15-year fixed rate
where the payment is no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay now why do
we do that just because we're killjoys
just because we don't want life to be
good for you no we do that because we
love you we care about your financial
future more than that Banker does more
than the mortgage companies do we're not
making money off of this off of the you
getting a mortgage or not getting a
mortgage are you getting a house or not
getting a house it's okay we're okay
you're okay but here's the thing
if you get in Crazy mode because of
what's going on out there you're going
to buy too much house you're gonna put
it on a 30-year and you're going to be
stuck in the middle class or lower
middle class Loop
all in the name of buying a house
because buying a house is financially
smart and
more bring money away Dave they're
throwing money away on rent that's the
argument calm down it sounds like a
weather forecaster when there's a
tornado warning that's the way your
brain sounds oh God God you know that's
their Super Bowl that's where they get
to create all the fear oh man
so yeah that's and when your brain is
doing that
so you know and people do it when you
know the first time I ever heard it was
like okay I live in California Mass
doesn't work in California well we kind
of know that but yes it does for
different reasons a lot of psychedelic
drugs involved in this but yes it does
work yeah so here's the thing
speaking of California Mass
CBS News is reporting one of the biggest
hurdles in buying a home is coming up
with a hefty down payment California has
a new program too End quotes help
first-time homebuyers jump that hurdle
what do you think George
oh boy keep reading you got it
California's forgivable Equity Builder
loan allows first-time home buyers who
have enough income for a monthly
mortgage payment to borrow up to 10 of a
home's purchase price to buy a house
outright the loan has an interest rate
of zero percent but borrowers who don't
occupy the home for at least five years
may have to repay the loan
what a concept so you can borrow your
down payment at zero percent
from California the new effort comes as
real estate prices have hit record high
is in California and Rising Rising your
trades have pushed
pushing payments
this is the way people's brains sound
I'm telling you I know exactly how your
brain sounds because this is how mine
sounds right before I do some stupid
butt stuff
it sounds like a beagle chasing a rabbit
is that what it sounds like I don't know
something like that but I mean your
brain your brain is shutting down but um
20 for a home in California could cost
upwards of a hundred thousand dollars
well no kidding that's the thing if you
get a million dollar home and they're
letting you borrow up to ten percent at
zero percent interest so letting you
borrow 100 Grand you still then have to
go get a 900 000 mortgage
and that's if your income qualifies now
that's assuming you qualifying but
here's the problem okay you can't look
out there five years in the future
and know what stupid but stuff the state
of California is going to do that makes
you want to leave
and you can't leave because then you
have to repay that loan today here is
the thing so even crazy people that
believe in debt are saying don't do it
aren't they George yeah oh yeah Credit
Karma came out and said this is probably
a bad idea if Credit Karma is saying
don't borrow the money
this tells you don't borrow the money I
mean this is like Jack Daniel's telling
you not to drink bourbon okay I mean
that's it's some Bad Bourbon right it's
got to be bad oh my God and I looked
into this your income has to be less
than 80 percent of the area median
income
and so they're saying if you're broke
enough you can then afford all of this
and like I said with the numbers housing
in California not cheap so even with the
borrowed money they're allowing people
to borrow way more to get into homes
they can't afford okay so these are less
than 80 so you're eight eight tenths of
the median the middle income of the area
tequila so this is um middle income or
lower middle income people only that are
going to get in this trap
yeah which are the people that can't get
a house oh God you're gonna get our
house listen I'm making fun of you
because I know how your brain sounds I
know that some of you are have a valid
concern about buying a home in this
market it's scary out there house prices
have shot up like crazy all the
indications of all the data from the
industry is it's going to calm down no
it's not going to come down it's going
to calm down and uh data that George and
I saw in a meeting yesterday was that uh
in 2020 house prices went up 32 percent
uh in 21 they went up what was it 18. 14
I think okay and they're expecting them
this year to go up seven percent so it's
slowing down so the rate of in and the
average house price year is about four
percent okay over the last 25 30 years
so we've had this huge Spike post
pandemic the spike is tapering off there
will continue to be a an appreciation an
increase in value but it will be more
reasonable and no you're not gonna get
priced out of the market if you continue
to grow your career you continue to
manage money well are you going to buy a
house right now probably not you might
be too broke to buy a house right now
you might be too broke to buy a car
right now you might be too broke to go
on vacation right now so don't do it
but Dave I gotta live my life yeah YOLO
baby YOLO I'm serious it all this stuff
is temporary and so calm your butt down
don't use the emotions of the current
inflationary cycle
to um cause you to dive off the deep end
into a pool with no water it's just
don't do it
don't do it calm
down
all right folks you're probably getting
the idea that buying a home involves a
lot more than just clicking through some
pictures online because if you sign the
dotted line on a new home and you're not
ready financially you're not ready
emotionally that house is going to end
up being a curse instead of a blessing
it will wind up owning you instead of
the other way around but when you're
ready a home can be a blessing for your
family and be a great way to build
wealth thanks for listening today share
this with the people you know who have a
case of house fever and don't miss the
next episode to learn how much house you
can really afford